I'm dr. Victor Zhao who said the council
on precision medicine I'm from Duke
University so the new model is one
called position medicine lotta people
used to call personalized medicine but
we feel that that's the so broad that it
could be subjected so many different
interpretation that perhaps precision
was what we want so in position medicine
will we be able to to do is to know the
exact mechanism the underlying
abnormality and therefore the diagnostic
and therapeutic modalities they can
result in improved treatment all
together in position in position
medicine we should be able to give one
time the right drug for the right
disease at the right time and it could
be a one-time treatment or it could be
chronic children but it does will not
involve multiple drugs model Charles and
errors so the critical issue here is
that we believe that technology
particularly these days using genomics
and many others are increasingly
enabling the possibility that we can
have that precision did we have the
precision I believe that with powerful
informatics who transformed altogether
the model of health care delivery but
perhaps more important for prevention
and wellness and in so doing pursues
position medicine will add value to
healthcare and transform health care all
together because we've greatly reduced
the cost of health care this is out
today's when we caught in Perry cold
medicine the trial and error that a
patient with high blood pressure could
be on three different drugs in order to
get blood pressure control and that most
of the blockbuster we know today really
only have effectiveness in forty percent
of population so in precision medicine
healthcare systems will have to change
that is delivery system you have to
think about our whole different way of
treating patients
developing a workforce that's educated
and perhaps using a different set of
rules all together and it will have to
also inform the public in terms of being
knowledgeable and being able to make the
right choices together with the
physicians and providers for this to
happen we have the align incentives and
also paving systems for the health
sector such as the pharmaceutical
industry the providers insurance
industry informatics all of them to work
together targeting at high priority
stratified population also we need a
policy and regulatory environment that
is adaptive that changes with new
knowledge and being able to encourage
that the scientific work and also the
adoption of this position diagnosis and
treatment and supports social values
that is equitable privacy and all those
issue as we begin the court this area so
this is a renew model I think this model
if actualized will transform all
together that we treat patients but more
importantly the way we do prevention and
improve health and that's really
transformational